how she her weight before to her weight
now good point like so is she not
perceived in a different way is she not
treated differently
but then it's not privileged though it's
more like she's being treated like it's
it's like that's it's the norm right
it's like yeah so so how okay
even while she had had a lot of weight
on the you know the body positivity
positivity movement was in there trying
like propping her up and everybody you
know
the movement's been around since like
2012. yeah around for a long time but
2012 i don't think is a long time to be
honest but um
so she's lost weight now and people are
praising them but she was also getting a
lot of hate from a lot of the people in
the body positivity movement who were
who looked at her and saw that okay
maybe the message he's trying to send to
other women is not um
a good one in that she's losing weight
she it's like
that whole movement it's it's just an
agenda like it's like
why not see that this person has